okay quick game i want you to name me a
self-driving taxi company ready three
two one go
right if you're in the us i'm guessing
you just said waymo or cruz as they're
the big u.s names in autonomous
ride-hailing but in china it's a
different story there companies like
auto x pony ai dd we ride and baidu's
apollo lead the way and some have even
carried paying passengers albeit with
support drivers and now they're headed
for the us specifically california where
almost half of the robo-taxi companies
that have permission to test without a
driver are chinese and recently auto x
announced it was opening a new
operations center in san francisco the
biggest attraction is really us being a
huge market yep that's one of china's
biggest autonomous driving companies
effectively setting up shop where waymo
and cruz operate so does this mean
you'll soon be able to hail a chinese
robo taxi on u.s roads and will that
give waymo and cruz a run for their
money let's find out
okay first i want to explore why the
market for autonomous vehicles or avs
seems to have exploded in china see
while u.s autonomous ride-sharing
companies had long led the way recently
chinese companies have accelerated their
efforts the mobility as a service is a
much easier case to happen in china
that's auto x's ceo jen chung xiao who
also goes by the name professor x china
market obviously is a great market is
the public largest in the world being
here we have the unique advantage that
because supply chain is here the
ecosystem the highway ecosystem here we
can build stuff easier we can iterate we
can design much faster what's more china
has also invested in zones where av
companies can test their vehicles you've
got what they call these cooperative
vehicle infrastructure systems or cvis
demonstration zones that's bill russo
ceo of automobility a consultancy firm
based in china and a man who has ridden
a few auto x's in his time if you've got
a cbis
infrastructure which includes roadside
units a whole lot of base stations and a
whole lot of connected infrastructure
that's stuff that that the av company
doesn't have to burden themselves with
it's that environment that has helped
these chinese companies gather troves of
data and grow quickly and now they're
expanding in the us and yes i did just
say expanding because some of these
chinese companies have actually been in
the united states for quite some time
you just might not have noticed them in
january 2017 we were the one of the
first company from china to actually get
the driving testing permit in california
you see in order to get started in the
driverless vehicle business in
california you need a few things firstly
there's testing permits from the
californian dmv and the californian
public utilities commission some of
which require you to have a support
driver while others don't once you've
got that you then need some vehicles on
the ground and a place to capture and
process all of the data you're gathering
and all of that takes time that's why we
establish a operation center there we
start building a roll coating there the
chinese companies have been making
headway last year their autonomous cars
collectively racked up over 450 000
miles on californian roads with pony ai
who have officers in california and
china being responsible for the vast
bulk of them for context even
collectively that's still way less than
weimar's 2.3 million miles and cruises
870 000 miles and crucially so far no
chinese company has secured a deployment
permit which would enable them to carry
paying passengers on some californian
roads but that might not matter
according to bill some of these chinese
companies may never actually intend on
carrying passengers in the united states
which begs the question what are they
doing in the u.s
it's very simple the most progressive
place on the planet for enabling the
testing and the measuring of the
effectiveness of the technology is
california they all want to prove
themselves out on the
at the major league level in california
right now for lack of an alternative is
the major leagues where you can meet the
rest of the world and compare yourselves
against the rest of the world what bill
told me is that he believed even though
china may be a bigger market for robo
taxis chinese companies may still need
to be seen in california in order to be
taken seriously by global investors if
you're going to
really raise the awareness of your name
and get the valuation high you need to
find a way to attract the you the global
capital investors and you're not going
to do that if you're not in the united
states it's a bit like new york fashion
week for lack of a better analogy sure
while you're there you hope you secure
orders but being seen among the
industry's elite is arguably just as
important when i spoke to chow i asked
him when i might see a driverless auto x
carrying paying passengers on u.s roads
and you couldn't really tell me yeah
we're definitely working very hard
towards that goal but as we as we always
be we always put safety as our highest
priority so while you might start to see
more and more chinese and international
driverless companies expanding their
operations in california it might be
quite some time before you get to ride
one of their vehicles across the golden
gate bridge
hey thanks for watching so do you think
you'll be able to ride a chinese robo
taxi on a us road anytime soon let me
know in the comments below and as always
if you're interested in the future of
how we might be getting from a to b then
don't forget to subscribe see you soon
[Music]
you